[Musique]
en anglais qui dit dans le cas nous
avons rétabli votre compte dans le cadre
de du rétablissement de de tous les
comptes qui avaient été banni voilà donc
moi je trouve que c'est une excellente
nouvelle pas seulement pour moi mais
c'est une excellente nouvelle pour la
liberté d'expression j'ajoute que
lorsque un homme qui est quand même
estampillé de droites en l'occurrence
Elon Musk reprend un réseau social il
réintègre effectivement un certain
nombre de comptes qui avaient été bannis
mais il ne restreint pas il ne bannit
pas il ne suspend pas les gens qui ne
pensent pas comme lui c'est-à-dire il y
a pas eu de demain qui s'est abattu de
censure qui s'est abattu sur les comptes
ou ok kystes gaucho progressistes etc
donc en fait tout le long alors juste
tout le monde a le droit de parler en
revanche je note que lorsqu'un réseau
social est aux mains d'un homme qui est
plutôt estampillé à gauche ou estampillé
progressivement Zuckerberg par exemple
sur Facebook vous avez des centaines et
des centaines de milliards pour la
France de compte qui ne sont pas ni à ni
de gauche ni progressiste et qui sont
soit rest
des gens mais je sais je sais que je
sais que une certaine réalité qui
percute frontalement votre idéologie
vous met mal à l'aise mais je vous il y
a des millions de Français qui pensent
exactement comment parce qu'ils voient
ce que je vois c'est à dire ce qu'il
faut voir vous ne voyez pas la question
de problèmes pardon ce qui t'a manqué
sur les réseaux allume pas du tout
il m'a jamais manqué il manquera jamais
je sais même pas qu'il avait été
suspendu vous voyez comme quoi je
m'intéresse je vous présente ce soir la
bienveillance et la bourre de gauche
alors
ça dépend de tous les soirs moi il m'a
pas du tout manqué j'étais très content
qu'il soit absent je vous attendais
Soulayman
c'est l'Autriche vous avez changé
Castaldi depuis 2000 l'émission on l'a
pas entendu il fait que des taux d'hiver
vous allez changer de nom pourquoi vous
avez peur qu'on vous appelle par votre
nouveau nom moi j'ai changé de nom
j'aimerais pas qu'on m'appelle par mon
nom d'origine voilà est-ce que vous
allez changer est-ce que vous allez
cesser de pour fendre les immigrés et
les musulmans est-ce que je vais arrêter
de voir le réel non non non je vais pas
rentrer dans une cécité militante comme
vous donc c'est toujours anti immigré
anti-musulman
je ne suis pas anti-immigré dehors les
immigrés on vient de dire votre nom les
immigrés attendez quand le président de
la République lui-même vous dit qu'il y
a un lien entre la délinquance la
criminalité et certaines immigrations ne
venaient pas le contredire sur ce
plateau que de grâce mais c'est pas
forcément voilà mais c'est pas forcément
comme vous laissez entendre le Maghreb
ou d'autres pays comme ça vous voyez si
on a l'immigration en général
massivement une immigration d'Amérique
du Sud ou d'Océanie il y a pas que ça
reste sur le tunnel Raymond moi je suis
pas sur mon réjouit pas qui reviennent
mais maintenant s'il reviennent bah
c'est la démocratie
c'est la liberté d'expression tant qu'il
reste dans le cadre de la loi après il
dit pas un jour sans moi j'ai des jours
où il se passe rien vous voyez pas un
jour sans vous il y a pas un jour tous
les jours il y a une grande régionale
ouvrez la presse quotidienne régionale
et vous serez surpris c'est pas un c'est
plusieurs ah oui oui c'est où non mais
vous lisez quel journal si vous lisez le
monde il se passe rien hein
regardez votre twitch moi qui reviennent
toi exactement ce que moi tout seul à
qui on coupe le micro me manque par
définition voilà je trouve qu'on peut
pas comprendre l'évolution d'une société
si on ne peut pas entendre la voix de
tous ceux qui la composent voilà mais
j'en mets ça je pense qu'il est pas le
seul à penser ce qu'il pense et bah il a
le droit de faire porter la voix de ceux
qui pensent comme lui etc il serait
l'extrême gauche je penserait exactement
la même chose et je ne suis pas
l'extrême gauche je suis pas d'extrême
droite en plus je suis plutôt dans le
centre voilà mais je trouve que le fait
que tout le monde ait le droit de parole
c'est le fondement de la démocratie et
heureusement que on redonne la parole à
ceux qui ont des choses à dire qu'on
soit d'accord ou pas avec eux je suis je
suis pas pour par exemple qu'on coupe la
chic à Gilles Verdez je danse
radicalement à l'opposé de ce qu'il
pense mais il ne me viendrait pas à
l'esprit de vous mais moi je veux pas
détruits entre une catégorie vous faites
des tweets qui énerve des millions de
Français parce qu'ils sont anti réels si
vous voulez c'est pas pour ça qu'on va
vous couper la chique votre problème
attendez de courriel fantasmer les
musulmans sont mauvaises étaient dehors
qui en France est-ce que vous dites vous
savez le racisme c'est pas une opinion
c'est un délit et le délit il est
décrété il est jugé par la justice c'est
pas à une entreprise privée ou c'est
même pas à des individus qui au prétexte
qui sont choqués par certaines opinions
qu'il re badigeonnent ça haine et
racisme pour mieux le censurer vous
comprenez ce que je veux dire c'est la
justice c'est un tribunal qui décide de
ce qui est haineux de ce qui est raciste
ou pas c'est ni agile Verdez ni à
Twitter ni à personne moi je n'ai jamais
été condamné pour la haine et d'ailleurs
si vous dites que j'incite à la haine ou
que je ou que je suis dans la haine je
peux vous poursuivre pour diffamation
parce que ça n'est pas le cas je n'ai
jamais été condamné pour ça alors
Géraldine toi c'est non non moi en fait
vous élucubrations et vos pensées en
fait je les connais donc en fait ça ça
ne m'intéresse pas plus que ça vous
Twitter tant mieux vous Twitter pas tant
mieux tant pis tout va en revanche quand
vous dites Elon Musk vous applaudissez
le messe dès demain en disant c'est
formidable de la rétabli rassurez-moi
vous êtes quand même pour qu'il
interdisent les violeurs les antisémites
les pédocrinels les terroristes tout à
fait se réjouir
tout ce que vous soulignez là madame
c'est c'est contraire à la loi
l'antisémitisme non qui ça vous vous
avez jamais été condamné pour la haine
ou pour incitation à la haine jamais
vous avez jamais été condamné pour 1500
euros d'amende pour avoir un jury le
préfet des Yvelines a mis des
djihadistes c'est une injure publique
mais c'est pas une incitation à la haine
et oui mais vous l'avez d'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs le problème
le procès est en cours c'est pas
définitif donc c'est je vous permets pas
de dire ça ben moi j'ai vu que c'était
définitive non c'est pas définitif donc
vous avez fait appel de la décision
d'accord mais là en première instance on
vous apprend d'aller exactement mais
donc c'est très bien en fait
ne faites pas d'amalgame parce que là
vous emballez le truc comme ça toute
vitesse un jour publique c'est pas un
citation à la haine c'est
attendez si vous voulez virer tous les
gens qui ont une colle la moindre
condamnation de Twitter il va pas rester
grand monde ce que je veux dire c'est
que je trouve ça très bien quand
justement les lois de la République
s'empare de Twitter quand il y a
évidemment une sortie de route et à ce
moment-là on est condamné où on n'est
pas condamné
pour diffamation par Bernard
laviraldière elle est toujours sur
Twitter pourquoi vous lui dites pas et
ben de la même manière je vous rappelle
vous avez vous avez une petite amnésie
à tout le monde où elle s'applique de
manière sélective en fonction de ce que
vous aimez
voilà c'est tout
l'assumez toi oui oui je pense que la
plateforme Twitter est en fait à l'image
de cette émission il faut de la
confrontation d'idées pour faire avancer
les choses donc tout simplement si on
lit Twitter c'est comme si on lissait
cette émission ça n'aurait plus de sens
et ça ne ferait pas avancer les choses
je précise que ici par exemple quand je
viens je viens pas en terrain conquis
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire mais
Cyril Hanouna a toujours victimiser
le courage d'inviter sur ce plateau et
je dis ça sans flagornerie et merci a
toujours le courage d'inviter sur ce
plateau toutes les opinions toutes les
opinions quelles qu'elles soient la
question qu'on nous pose c'est ce que
vous nous avez manqué honnêtement moi
vous m'avez pas manqué vous vous êtes là
c'est bien vous n'êtes pas c'est pas
grave
je termine genre en revanche
effectivement là-haut bah oui c'est
normal comme ça c'est normal parce que
comme ça vous met de la lumière mais du
coup j'ai pas besoin
de lumière à moi tout seul
[Applaudissements]
effectivement moi je suis comme un petit
camarades moi ça me pose aucun problème
que vous ayez le droit de vous exprimer
encore une fois dans le respect de la
loi dans le cadre de la loi et moi ce
que je veux c'est que les gafams
collabore avec la loi et c'est pas
toujours le cas et c'est la seule moi
c'est le seul problème que j'ai avec
cette idée de on va remettre en place
tous les bannis et tous les bannis
pourront dire ce qu'ils veulent moi ok
pour rétablir tout le monde si les gars
femme coopèrent réellement et
efficacement avec la loi avec la justice
parce que parfois on a beau leur
demander la justice à beau aller les
chercher la police a beau leur demander
il vous donne pas les adresses IP etc
etc donc quand là il y aura cette
égalité là moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord pour qu'il y ait évidemment une
libre parole sur au long de quoi je
c'est une question que je pose au nom de
quoi on va interdire de s'exprimer
quelqu'un juste sous le prétexte qu'il
n'est pas d'accord avec qu'est-ce que la
majorité je suis d'accord avec vous donc
soit on rétablit la liberté d'expression
pour tout le monde moi personnellement
je lutte pour que tout le monde ait la
liberté d'expression si demain on
m'annonce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou l'un
des membres de la France insoumise pour
donc pourtant je suis aux antipodes de
l'idéologie et censuré pour des raisons
obscures ce qui a été mon cas je me
battrai pour qu'il puisse s'exprimer si
vous voulez juste je je il y a des gens
qui disent parce que c'est ça c'est
c'est le sujet en plus c'est pas du tout
un pote hein
il nous fait chier aussi pourquoi vous
appelez sur Twitter à faire bloquer le
compte de Jean-Michel Apathie vous avez
dit ça non mais c'était une blague vous
avez vu comment le comment le tweet est
formulé c'est son premier c'était une
boutade d'accord donc vous voyez pas
bien sûr que non vous rigolez très bien
alors
vous dites que vous êtes fidèle dans vos
opinions alors un petit coup ancien RN
après porte-parole des émours vous êtes
où là maintenant c'est plus mais c'est
quoi le rapport avec le sujet en fait
mais si c'est intéressant c'est pas à
tout ce que toute la haine que vous
déversez en général je ne vous permet
pas de dire ça la haine vient de tous
ceux qui la liberté d'expression la
connaissez tous ceux qui ben justement
la liberté c'est pour ça que je peux le
dire je peux le dire moi aussi mais sauf
que moi je vous interdis pas de le dire
contrairement à vous et ben je vous le
redis alors je déverse pas de la haine
non ben si moi je pense que Jean vous
déversez de l’arrête avec ton cigare
vous défaire c'est de la moi je dis moi
je dis moi je t'ai dit que tu me
manquais donc comme vous avez mignon toi
c'est pas moi qui c'est pas moi qui suis
haineux c'est toi qui dit que je suis
pas une voilà c'est toi qui suis-je
pas déverser la haine c'est pas bien non
mais dire non mais c'est pas excusez-moi
mais la haine elle est dans le réel je
veux dire moi on commence pas avec ça je
vais vous dire un exemple lorsque les
féministes
brocardent les hommes parce qu'ils sont
prépondérants dans les violences
conjugales est-ce qu'on dit qu'ils font
des amalgames on dit que c'est juste
factuel
c'est factuel donc quand on dit que
certaines immigrations sont sur
représentées dans la description c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas une idéologie
factuel c'est tout ça vous emmerde mais
c'est factuels
Castaldi après on passe à autre chose
j'ai mis oui vous m'avez pas manqué
parce que je vous suis pas vraiment sur
les réseaux sociaux mais je ne suis pas
d'accord avec toutes vos opinions mais
je sais j'adore les hommes avec des gros
barreaux d'ailleurs donc
je trouve qu'il y a tellement c'est
encore moi j'en ai marre de l'hypocrisie
c'est à dire qu'on tombe tous sur Jean
Messia en lui enlève son compte avec les
menaces de mort qui a tous les jours le
cyber-harcèlement
sexuels pour les enfants
pédocriminalité mais je trouve ça mais
d'un ridicule on tombe tous sur Jean
Messia ok moi quand je vois ce tweet là
je l'aime pas je n'aime pas d'accord
mais excusez-moi est-ce que Jean Messia
et l'homme le plus dangereux de France
je ne crois pas il a pas des idées que
je partage mais faut arrêter avec cette
hypocrisie il y a beaucoup plus urgent
que d'arrêter le compte de gens
messieurs c'est une question à poser à
Souleyman est-ce que
tu as marqué est-ce que est-ce que vous
trouvez le soleil man est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous trouvez ça normal non
mais je l'appelle pour sa nouvelle
identité parce que dans son esprit c'est
insultant moi c'est quelqu'un la
question si quelqu'un appelle Mohamed
Ali Cassius CLA je dirais non il a
choisi de s'appeler Mohamed Ali pourquoi
l'application donc c'est pareil
la question est-ce que vous trouvez ça
normal que par exemple le compte d'Ali
kamenei le président de la République
islamique d'Iran sur lequel il déverse
des idées très progressistes comme
l'élimination de d'Israël et une
nouvelle Shoah à l'encontre des juifs
est-ce que vous trouvez ça normal que
pendant que moi je suis banni le compte
Twitter d'alica manège reste ouvert
est-ce que vous trouvez ça normal que le
porte-parole des talibans qui appelle à
des idées très progressistes comme
l'immolation des homosexuels soit
toujours sur Twitter alors que moi je
suis banni est-ce que c'est ça la
liberté d'expression ça d'après vous je
peux répondre allez-y pour moi les
comptes que vous venez de citer et le
vôtre doivent être
bannisez la question répondez de manière
de manière
idéologique eux doivent être bannis et
vous aussi une étroit pour moi vous
dispensez la mort pas du tout histoire
merci au revoir